13 يوما مرت على وقوع الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا على عتبه اسبوعين
الحصيله ليست نهائيه العدد الكلي للضحايا
في البلدين وصل اليوم الى اكثر من 46 الفا
تمر الايام الساعات والثواني نحو انعدام
الامل في ايجاد ناجين ربما تكتب هاتاي
الاكثر تضررا بين المقاطعات التركيه نهايه
معجزات الكارثه ثلاثه اشخاص تم انقاذهم
اليوم كما نتابع قضى من بينهم طفل في
المستشفى نجا اثنان حتى الان بعد 300 ساعه
قضاياها تحت الانقاض وكثيره هي الماسي
التي نتجت عن زلزال تركيا وسوريا اسوا
كارثه منذ قرن مئات الالاف من الناجنه
مشردون والاف الاطفال الابرياء بات مصيرهم
العراء واليتم منهم من تركوا او اسم
مسؤوله الصحه في تركيا وسوريا يحاولون
مطابقه الاطفال مجهولين هويه بالعناوين
لكن اي عناوين بعد ان طمست ملامح البيوت
في مدينه اسكندرون المنكوبه مثلا هناك
اكثر من 260 طفلا مصابا لم يتم التعرف
عليهم بعض الاطفال حتى لا يستطيعون نطق
اسمائهم الصدمه النفسيه كانت شديده بحسب
احدى عاملات الاغاثه في بلده جنديرس وبعض
اخر في سن مبكره ويصعب اصلا التواصل معهم
هكذا تؤكد احدى متطوعات تقدم الدعم النفسي
والاجتماعي للقصر في شمال غرب سوريا
اطفال مجهولون الهويه هم ضحايا الزلزال
المميته في تركيا كتبت لهم النجاه لكنهم
فقدوا ذويهم ولا يمكن التعرف على هويات
معظمهم حتى الان الارقام الرسميه ذكرت
قرابه 1400 طفل تم انقاذهم دون التعرف على
ذويهم في بدايه الامر لكن السلطات استطاعت
تحديده الف منهم ونجحت الجهود في لم شمل
500 طفل مع اسرهم وتم تحويل البقيه الى
المشاكل لتلقي العلاج وزاره الاسره
والخدمات الاجتماعيه استضافت 200 طفل لم
يتم التعرف على هويتهم حتى اللحظه مجلس
البحث العلمي والتقني التابع لبرنامج
التعرف على الوجوه في تركيا استطاع لوحده
تتبع هويات
144 طفلا وجاري العمل على تتبع هويات
البقيه